previously on TV sins what is it you
want to say to me don't you look like
squeezed dick got a little blue vein not
left the side of your head see that's
where I put the bullet but I have to
stand back how she look like you'd be a
squirter
several of these envelopes slip past
quality control and remain unsealed sure
I could sin that nobody caught it or I
could send that it will be lost in the
mail but no I'm sitting Pheebs here
because she is clearly so dehydrated
that she ran at us alive up this is the
most dangerous envelope licking
development since we lost Susan yeah
nothing I'm sure they'll be impressed
with your excellent computer skills
[ __ ] there are like 15 of you here
and no one caught this before you
started stuffing it's only one goddamn
page also I cuz Ross being such a dick
here I wonder it takes him so long to
get on the will day side of the Ross
Rachel paradigm no I'm sure the Xerox
machine caught a fuel setting the
outdated joke aside is this really a
Joey line he's the dumb one right I know
the writer is probably want to spread
the jokes around but that should have
been a Chandler line and I'm not taking
second opinions kind of dances David
Schwimmer going with here I know I know
the show is so revered now that this
moment is just accepted but I'm not
letting this guy off the hook without an
explanation for the slo-mo fist pump
bull during a massively up-tempo theme
song and speaking of problems with the
opening credits what's going on with
Courtney Cox shutting down the power to
an entire city block when she turns off
the lamp here this was March of 1995 man
and someone was just watching the
O'Bannon brothers dominate for UCLA
before this completely preventable power
failure occurred
lots responses sure we have scones
laughs come the hell on with this ruse
like Rachel's never around with her
friends during a shift at Central Perk
dear Miss Brie thank you for your
inquiry however no so Rachel got all
these responses and all of them are
knows all the companies took the time to
write and mail a letter to someone who's
blindly applying for entry-level work
don't get me wrong that's very polite
but it's also very preposterous Wow what
visa bill is huge
visa envy I can hear my mother now get
those dirty feet off that chair someone
has to sit there of course we would then
get into an argument about the relative
cleanliness of butts versus feet so
basically this scent is from my mother
also I'm upset that we never got the
episode we're gonna have to close down
Central Perk for good because no one
else would ever come here because of and
I quote those sick people who talk way
too loud about all the books in their
lives do any of you know how to play no
but you could teach us no okay look
sitcoms got a sitcom and all but there
was no way those guys could have
delivered that synchronized no without
at least glancing at each other first to
clue each other in on the joke as if it
doesn't strain reality enough on TV that
everyone immediately
would he answer to everything we're
adding mind-read into the mix okay I
just need to ten of Spades in the six of
clubs why would anyone ever need two
specific cards of different suits if she
already had the other three she might
know the suit but she can't have the
other three of both and sure the show is
asking us to believe that girls are
idiots when it comes to poker but
shouldn't we at least know why Phoebe
think she means these specific cards you
can't I'm not sure when this episode
will be done with the art girls the
stupidest at poker stick but I'm pretty
sure Rachel would know the difference
between a spade and heart maybe just
throw away two jacks because they didn't
look happy how do you know this we've
been here for this entire conversation
and she hasn't said jack about any Jack
you gotta settle so what the Jamestown
Colony of Virginia you see King George
is giving us to land sure George the
third was King during the American
Revolution but Jamestown was actually
settled way before that in fact the king
that gave the land for Jamestown was are
you ready King James how did you get
that from the I love Rachel pizzeria
he's still long that yes he is and so
was the show only for another six notes
218 episodes
little-known fact that what Chomsky's
were huge fans of friends and this
poster inspired them to make their Speed
Racer movie and that's where the sin for
the movie and another for for the
revisionist historians who think it's
any good I might've had feelings for her
at one time not anymore the writers were
like people are probably getting tired
of attention we're building with the
Ross and Rachel love interests but we
have a solution you were not putting
that on again okay monkey
hello kettle this is Monica you're black
that's racist okay something everything
you hear at a poker game is pure crap
yeah that checks out but this little
lesson will have very little payoff in
this episode since aside from some
Rachel Luck the girls will continue to
play completely lousy poker obvious
trick cards are obvious also the shuffle
is about as intimidating as a litter of
puppies rolling around in a basket of
multicolored feathers the first answer
is yes people did wear dress shirts over
patterned sweaters in the 90s and the
second answer is yes it was just as much
of a sin then as it is now well I'm
gonna order a piece or you can walk
across the hall to your own apartment in
order a pizza setting aside the serious
gourmet she whips up how the hell does
Monica cook anything in this kitchen
there's no prep space don't tell me it's
because there's no counter room she's
got all this equipment and large
containers sitting right there where she
could be chopping I've seen dorm room
that have larger meson plus alright
Cincinnati no blinds everybody in all
right Monica will say you actually want
to play Cincinnati even though it hasn't
been popular since well ever
why are you dealing everyone two cards
down one card up generally the kind of
deal would be a stud type game unlike
Cincinnati which is more similar to
Omaha in that it uses four cards to each
player and four community cards to make
your best hand beer I mean well you
better hop out of the shower because I
got a flush you had four of a kind in a
five card game and you didn't raise this
overhead shot clearly shows everyone
evenly spaced out around the table but
when it cuts back to the normal view
it's clear that there's a gap between
Chandler and Phoebe for shooting reasons
that's what you get for trying to be all
fancy networks it come stay in your lane
I will string bets oh and this will
happen several more times so let's just
see that sin and raise it nine more for
good measure ah yes the 90s when sexual
misconduct was hilarious I just lost a
job and I'd like to raise the bed five
bucks does anybody have a problem with
that well since you asked yes I could go
into yet another diatribe about sticking
to the poker rules of the house but
instead I'll point out that Rachel can't
lose a job she never had I saw you're 25
and I raised you seven teams Joey I'm a
little shy so we after an entire evening
a poker you both somehow had the exact
same amount of chips and had to bring
out cash at the exact same time I know
this is becoming the one about the poker
sins but prince has completely taken the
crown from Casino Royale as the worst
representation of poker on camera in the
history of poker and we were made for
this look how happy she is I think
there's always bothered me about this
show is how they pretend that they
couldn't hear each other at convenient
times while in the same apartment there
what six feet away having said that this
is why the show freakin rule the beauty
of Ross is love followed directly by the
joke of them realizing what happened the
show may not get poker but it gets
relationships and this moment alone is
strong enough to force me to fold a few
back
licking envelopes can be fun all you
have to do is make a game of it ladies
Pheebs how many do you want okay I just
need to son of a [ __ ] we want a rematch
well that's fine with me
good use the money well the jerk stark
old they're running out of you don't
expect me to be a nice guy no more mr.
nice duck don't splash the father